now international monitors say UN
peacekeepers task of protecting
civilians in South Sudan hidden their
bases when fighting erupted earlier this
year it follows claims that the Sudanese
government has been using chemical
weapons on its own people in nearby
Darfur since January of attention taken
up by that civil war in Syria and to a
much lesser extent the war in Yemen
charities are asking when the
international community will make
serious attempts to resolve the crisis
in East Africa Maddie krovas the head of
communications and research at the
charity waging peace and she joins me
live malformed at central London and
Maddie you're saying a saddening and
sickening as the reports of use of them
chemical weapons are you're not
surprised I'm afraid we're not so at
waging peace we talk regularly with
members of the Sudanese diaspora in the
UK and what they're telling us is that
they've heard these reports before it
might be a bit graphic but we've heard
reports of people's bodies expanding and
even exploding after death and smoke
that would darken in the sky so I'm
afraid it's something that we've we've
been experiencing before and I think the
UK Sudanese diaspora is quite keen for
action to now be taken on this well this
is a conflict that's been going on since
2003 tell a little bit more about what
you are seeing on the ground so
alongside the allegations of chemical
weapons that obviously need to be
investigated fully the Amnesty
International report there actually
documented them reports on the more
systematic forms of violence that have
been occurring in Darfur since 2003 as
you mentioned so that includes the
destruction of villagers it includes
bombing of civilian targets like schools
and hospitals mass rapes so those sort
of things have been continuing for now
well into their 13th year so it's this
should really be a wake-up call to the
international community about chemical
weapons and a red line are in in our
engagement with the regime to actually
do something about what's been occurring
there for so long I mean these are these
are weapons that are essentially band
and the student Sudanese government has
consistently and denied any use of
chemical weapons what are your your
reports and claims
stone so obviously Amnesty
International's report is the most
credible account we have at the moment
but that's only because the Sudanese
government is blocking access to the
area what's needed now is a full
thorough and independent investigation
and that should be carried out by the
same bodies that responded to the
allegations in Syria so the organisation
for the prohibition of chemical weapons
which has looked at the reports already
but says it needs to gain access or a UN
fact-finding mission perhaps under the
aegis of the Security Council or
alternatively the Human Rights Council
okay Maddy let's let's take a closer
look exactly and what the Sudanese
government has said and they said
they've utterly say the claims that are
they found them unfounded allegations of
baseless fabricated and and they're
claiming it's just an attempt to steer
confusion in the ongoing peace process I
mean what I'd say to them is that our
goal should be exactly the same which is
access to prove or disprove the
allegations if they feel they have
nothing to hide they need to give access
to that area for the bodies that can
investigate that gate those claims to
actually go in and do that and they
should also provide humanitarian access
to that region more generally the reason
that some of these claims can look you
know fabricated in some way is simply
because the amnesty researchers could
only go off satellite imagery and could
only go off phone calls to people on the
ground I think they are credible though
and they are serious and they need to be
taken seriously by the international
community and that's the problem and
you're suggesting today that not enough
is being done by the international
community and distracted by my conflicts
in Syria we were just talking about it
earlier not even just by the conflict in
Syria but I think domestic pressures to
do with migration have encouraged us to
engage in a process called the cartoon
process to try and stem migration from
and through the Horn of Africa and that
has led us to engage with regimes like
Sudan to try and reduce the numbers
rightfully fleeing the violence that
it's perpetrating in in their area so
it's not even you know external
pressures it's also domestic pressure
that I think is leading us into the arms
of regimes that are
you know guilty of chemically murdering
and maiming their own civilians now this
conflict has been going on for 13 years
and double than the conflict and
comparing it to Syria what do you think
needs to be done to to bring some kind
of resolution to this I really think in
terms of the chemical weapons in
particular there needs to be an
investigation into this obviously the
use of chemical weapons isn't the only
issue in the region but this should
really be a wake-up call to us that
we've allowed the Sudanese government to
sort of bomb kill and rape its own
civilians with complete impunity for
such a long time I think in the Amnesty
International report they called it an
act of hubris that you know obviously
the government of Sudan thinks it can
get away with something of this level of
severity and that it won't be a red line
in our engagement I think it has to be
and I think it should force us to to
wake up and act okay Medicare they're
speaking to us from the charity waging
peace thank you very much